last night's Republican debate was held
at the Reagan Library just 40 minutes
from this studio where we tape our show
it is so close that I decided to send
our own Andy Richter over to cover this
incredibly historic event how'd it go
Andy well I mean I got stuck in traffic
so by the time I got there all the seats
in the audience were full but I still
did get to see the debate and I got some
tape of me there so take a look dr.
Carson because he too has been skeptical
of your plan to immediately deport 11 to
12 million illegal immigrants he said
quote people who propose giving these
undocumented immigrants
grace period to pay back taxes don't
elect them become guest workers every
person who comes into this country on a
Visa and when they overstay their visa
we need to tap them on the shoulder and
say you have overstayed your welcome
your people
[Music]
you narrow the Republican field I'll be
yeah I'm up until now I did not realize
I ground the three of them up hey thanks
for watching be sure to click subscribe
to see even more great Conan clips you
may now return to your pirated movies
and creepy Japanese pornography